sweet innocent victoria uh when we
brought up relationships earlier you
said you're
hopelessly single
deadly but yeah
did you say helplessly or hopelessly
i didn't say any of that you said deadly
singles
okay you're gorgeous you're smart you're
cool thanks uh you're a lawyer you've
got a good personality
why can't you lock down a man
that's the question i've been having
yeah
well honestly i
i don't know i just feel like maybe it's
my
peer group that i'm dating i guess or
maybe just who i'm attracted to is just
not compatible with me so
i need to change my type
why what's your type now
um honestly if you're looking for a
funny asian guy i got you
[Laughter]
okay what's your type ah gosh well
i mean i did i do like a little younger
than me so maybe that's my problem
you're good you like a guys that are
younger than you yeah uh this i never
asked this question but how old are you
i'm 29. you're 29. okay and you're what
early 30s i just turned 40 last night
damn girl okay you're about to be 40. so
you're 29 and you're ideally like what
i don't know i mean i i just said
younger i do like younger like i mean i
don't know i mean you're trying to go
like high school hockey teacher thing i
don't know
why younger what kind of fetish you're
like a couple years younger why i i
don't know just something can i give you
some breaking news that [ __ ] ain't gonna
work out yeah yeah i mean that's true
but like i've dated you know why though
i've dated everyone from like a 45 year
old to like a 24 year old like i i feel
like maybe
i i don't know if it's social media it's
just the world we live in now
there's a lot of men especially in south
florida you're like 45 and they're like
i'm not ready to settle down yet yeah i
don't know any of those kind of guys out
there guys
uh they're just still ready to like keep
going to live in miami
that's that's maybe i know if you guys
like that
the uh
okay so you're attracted to younger guys
well i mean that's
the majority of my attraction but like
anybody i i really don't have a type and
maybe that is my problem maybe i'm just
like a shotgun just shooting everywhere
and i haven't really set a focus um
lately i've just been focused on myself
and my brand which has been really like
pivotal and crucial to me like just
being successful myself but uh
i just found out a lot of south florida
dating is just
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire saucecast click right
here
[Music]